the move that soft touch a couple
bounces in whoa whoa
is right that's embiid and listen
towns did something similar in the first
half grabbing embiid
and you think just to make sure that as
you're committing that
foul to stop him from getting to the
hoop that no further damage has caused
and that was the intent here
he is not trying to hurt him in any way
i think he's just trying to make sure he
commits the foul
prevent the hoop and no other harm
the officials were thinking about the
replay chris finch who already has the
technical
saying go to the replay i want a
flagrant yeah they want to play with
fouls
the whole bench up just confused as to
how you
can't even entertain the thought of a
flagrant foul
so that was joelle here's what happened
a little earlier
and that's with the guy who isn't
worried about how joelle is landing at
least joelle made sure townes landed
safely
embiid now with nine and the sixers
their largest lead at eight as town goes
and then slows
over embiid
extension from carl anthony towns
again this is what you're taught growing
up attack the rim
reckless abandon have a confrontation
at the rim second and then he cuts hard
to the basket ben
finds him carry his first hoop as
towns missed from beyond
joelle had that post up yep
and harris there was surrounded by
minnesota timberwolves says embiid you
can kill it
and a foul he's fired up and so is the
crowd at wells fargo center
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah we're talking about mere mortals
earlier
yeah that's the guy falling to the
ground
the immortal the sublime
oh my goodness joelle welcome back
towns his second and once again the
chance of
mvp
where were we last time oh is new york